trevis Todd as an American entrepreneur
he left silicon valley behind Tibet on
Berlin's burgeoning startup scene he's
founded three so far I saw the potential
of Berlin and saw that it was the right
place and right time to be here and kind
of have ridden that wave ever since it's
an international City everyone speaks
English it's really easy to network and
find like-minded creative people so it's
a really great place to be a young
creative startup founder this building
says Travis will be housing some of
Berlin's startups he's dubbed the
complex silicon Elaine a bilingual pun
that helps remind him of home he says
the city is ideal in terms of available
talent but Berlin's bureaucracy might
not quite be ready for it there's a lot
of trust issues with with self-employed
people or freelancers as well and
dealing with the phone on Santa's well
the taxes already treats you like your
corporation and you have an accounting
department and a bookkeeping department
and know all the rules and can fill out
all the correct forms even when you're
just a soul entrepreneur the Berlin
government has promised to remove such
hurdles in the meantime Stefan funds get
the city's business promotion agency
Berlin partner are helping international
entrepreneurs navigate the city's
bureaucracy among you touch a chakram
combined we help when someone comes here
and for example needs a visa or has to
cope with something involving
bureaucracy the forms are in German of
course but we have a business
immigration service in place if
companies get in touch with us we
guarantee that the job will be done
within a week definitely do this but
guru Chris is not the only challenge
financing is also a big issue in Europe
but what Berlin has is potential and
entrepreneurs and the German capital are
banking on it